[Music]
at least one person has been killed and
several injured in Russian drone strikes
in the Ukrainian Capital Ukraine's
military says it downed 52 of the 54
drones that were launched overnight
officials say it was the largest drone
attack on the city since the beginning
of the war kiev's mayor warned people to
stay indoors and said more drone attacks
could Target the capital
Natasha Butler is live for us from Kiev
Natasha what happened
yeah another very difficult night here
for people in Kiev who were awake for uh
much of it because of what Ukrainian
officials are saying was the biggest
drone attack on the capital since the
full-scale invasion uh began they say
that Ukrainian air defense took down a
52 out of 54 drones that were launched
by Russia now as far as we know one
person was killed by some falling debris
some other people were injured and there
was a building to uh there was damage to
a number of buildings in the capital
these sort of attacks really have been
intensifying over the past few weeks
this is in fact the 14th attack of this
kind overnight since the beginning of
May alone and Russian forces really have
been intensifying these attacks in the
capital many are saying it's ahead of
Ukraine's anticipated character
offensive are counter-offensive that
some say has already begun but others
certainly saying it is imminent
how are people coping with these regular
attacks Natasha
look it's very difficult at night of
course because people are losing a lot
of sleep they're having to get up in the
night because of the sound of the
explosions they're often scared going to
shelters but then the next day they have
to get up and get on with it people are
going to school they're going to work to
University and if you walk around the
city even this morning you know the
shops are open the cafes are open people
are out and about and today is a special
day here in Kiev because it's kieve day
it is the anniversary of the founding of
Ukraine's Capital more than 1 500 years
ago and people say they're going to
celebrate there are concerts and events
that are organized more subdued than in
previous years before the war but
nevertheless people are determined to
continue living their lives not just to
show resilience for them but they say
this is just a way to show Moscow that
they won't be broken by these constant
night attacks and Natasha Butler
reporting from Kiev thank you very much